même si vous optez pour l'
estimation la plus prudente qui est d'au moins
272 ans,
le requin du Groenland est toujours le
plus vieil animal vertébré
que nous
connaissons, c'est incroyable d'avoir pu
faire ce travail avec une si grande cabane en haute mer
que personne ne sait  beaucoup à
ce sujet
[Musique]
voir un requin vert est super rare
parce qu'ils vivent dans l'atlantique et
ils vivent dans la mer profonde ils ont une
peau très rugueuse ils ont l'air vieux même
quand il y en a de petits
[Musique]
c'était énorme  surprise, nous avons trouvé
une estimation du requin le plus âgé de
notre étude avait entre
272 et 512 ans maintenant nous avons un
chiffre, nous avons quelque chose de solide à dire
même si nous ne pouvons pas dire l'âge exact
très
précis que nous pouvons dire avec
très haute certitude que c'est un
animal très ancien
[Musique]
il y en a un en particulier qui est souvent
présenté comme c'est un
requin du groenland de 400 ans mais le truc c'est que
ce requin particulier qui est là où il
y a cette image très cool de celui-ci  et
il a l'air très vieux et très gros, c'était
en fait un requin que nous avons
relâché avec des contrôles par satellite et
donc nous n'avons jamais
étudié son âge, donc il n'est pas
correct que cet animal spécifique soit
très vieux, mais il est vrai que l'
espèce requin du Groenland
peut être
les gens très âgés demandent toujours comment c'est de voir un
animal qui a
50 ans ou 100 ans et c'est
impressionnant
mais mais une chose qui est toujours plus dans mon
esprit est combien de temps il peut
réellement vivre après moi quand vous attrapez  un
requin de deux ou trois mètres alors vous
pensez oh wow cet animal il peut
en fait vivre encore 100 ou
200 ans et je pense que c'est assez
impressionnant je pense que c'est important en
termes de considérations de conservation et
des choses comme ça le groenland  les requins sont
des espèces qui sont appelées une capture d'espionnage
dans certaines pêcheries ou nous nous attendons à ce que les
femelles aient en fait plus de 100 ans
lorsqu'elles
atteignent la maturité sexuelle et ce
nombre devrait en quelque sorte
déclencher tous les signes avant-coureurs indiquant
si l'espèce est en voie de disparition,
mais la prochaine  la question qui vient ensuite
dans l'argile est de savoir combien de bouffées obtiennent-elles
pour la grossesse, nous savons où les lions
accouchent ou où les crocodiles accouchent et
comment ils le font et combien d'œufs ils
obtiennent ou des tortues ou des choses comme ça mais
quand il s'agit de l'océan  et
surtout quand il s'agit de la mer profonde,
toutes ces questions fondamentales deviennent
euh pertinentes, mais ici au Groenland, elles
sont les plus courantes de 200 mètres à
700 mètres et le record le plus profond
d'un requin vert est à près de trois
kilomètres en ce moment je
ne la considèrerait pas en voie de disparition mais c'est
une espèce qui devrait être gardée sous
haute surveillance et surtout les
méthodes de signalement devraient être améliorées
[Musique]
vous